impressed are you with magnus
finding that plan and magnus's play in
this game
i'm highly impressed to be honest i mean
he firstly he looks super focused uh
which hasn't always been the case in the
prelims but
secondly
even after he got that chance he's been
ruthless i mean he actually traded off
everything the queens the rooks um pawns
just to make it as safe as possible and
he's still got this advantage of two
bishops against one lone rook um so yeah
magnus actually if we analyze this he's
probably played a perfect game wow i
don't think we can fault any of his
moves and meanwhile hans has tried he's
only actually made one mistake hands but
at this top level
that's all it takes yeah unfortunately
there are different types of mistakes
you know you have your slight
inaccuracies where the game about
evaluation doesn't change that much you
have blunders
where you know you kind of
your your opponent has the
um initiative has the flow and then you
have like game changing blunders and
okay there you go you can see it has
neiman has resigned magnus carlsen has
won wow